[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review
of the new film becky starring lulu
wilson and kevin james
so what's really interesting about this
movie is its choice of its opening
shot with becky that we actually see
where she is at the end of the film
where she's at the police station and
she's getting interrogated about what
happened
the directors definitely chose to show
this first because they weren't
concerned about you knowing that
she makes out of this alive they're
telling you that right from the first
couple of seconds
they wanted you to see how we got to
this
sociopathic murderer becky by the end of
all this so they're showing you
her in that state in the beginning and
then they go back two weeks earlier and
then we see how it all follows through
now one of the other opening sequences
is cutting back and forth
between kevin james's character in the
prison
and becky's character and it's lining up
her life like she's living in
a prison and that she feels like an
outcast and that she will eventually
become a murderer like
these prisoners they set that up and
give you hints to that really well
and they show little moments that are
important just in the beginning when
she's in the gas station with her father
and she's looking around at happy
families especially mothers
and her mother we learned passed away so
it's already given her this jagged edge
and a hate
for the world in a sense what works
really well about this movie
is that the character of apex who is the
sidekick to kevin james character his
son not by blood but in their
brotherhood is basically this big
friendly giant we finally see
and that he actually is going through a
transformation from being a murderer who
killed kids
this white supremacist to actually
coming full around to someone who wants
to be peaceful again and not
kill and change for the good even though
like he says he has all these stains
he says to becky at a point you still
have
time you're a kid you know to run away
from this
and we see the opposite end of the movie
is becky transforming into
a murderer and what i think they are
getting at a lot and i think it works
well is a hint
that becky is kind of this beginning of
this girl who might become
a white nationalist now the symbol that
we see on this key
the symbol that the tattoos that kevin
james and apex have
is all the same symbol it's used a lot
for white nationalist groups
and at the end she's staring at that key
and is just admiring it and it's it's
scary
and it's really interesting because
there's hints that the mother was a
white nationalist you
hear this when becky says about gonna be
stepmom that
her mom would have hated her and that
the mom
maybe knew about this key being in the
basement unless it was just there before
they got there they didn't really kind
of give you that answer but
i think they leave that for you to
question and i think they leave you to
question
is becky actually thinking about
becoming that person is she becoming
the people that ruined her family it's
almost like you're expected to believe
she'll eventually get to the level
of apex and the tragedy of it is that
apex finally changes
and becky's the one to kill him even
though he spared her and saved her life
in the end her not showing him mercy she
just becomes the monster she
stopped this whole movie and they're
giving you that that she's gonna be
horrid too they hint that out with the
poster of the movie where
it starts with a little rhyme about
there was a little girl
and the end of that rhyme being once she
was bad she was hard which becky becomes
and it's cool how they blend that in
where they hear the doll toys say that
in the middle of the movie and then she
says on the walkie-talkie to kevin james
later on and what's cool about this
movie
it really is an homage to home alone but
it's home alone on steroids it's home
loan rated r
which is really kind of cool to see play
out i mean you see she's got
the winter hat that's definitely to pay
respects to kevin mcallister from home
alone
a big home alone esque scene is when she
actually shouts out to the
bald henchmen later on in the movie
saying want the key gotta catch me first
lures him into a trap with a fishing net
and eventually
kills him with a motor it's all a setup
of home alone which is just cool to see
it go full
gore level and i love good body gore if
you watch my reviews you know that about
me and i thought this movie
did not disappoint that department and
what was really cool
is they had really awesome and creative
kills in particular
thought the best one had to be when she
gets on the roof of her fort
throws a quarter out at the guy in the
orange camouflage
and makes him think it's the key then
kills him with a ruler
by getting down to him through a zip
line
that was amazing and i love they just
went full
on here and then lulu wilson just went
full psychopath screaming and just
stabbing him in the throat
consistently with the ruler i'm happy
they went balls to the walls with it
that was awesome to watch another great
gruesome moment
was to have it work emotionally and
full-on
shock value as well is when the dad gets
killed and shot and right after she
stabs kevin james in the eye with
the key that was incredible and it led
to what this movie had a lot of which
was actually some really funny humor in
it
i love the scene where his eyes just
dangling out and then the bald henchman
cuts it out with just arts and crafts
scissors and kevin james is like what
are you doing
and they gave the henchman with the
orange camouflage some great funny lines
here when kevin james says him does that
look like a dog's backpack
and he goes dogs don't have backpacks or
when he's going
after becky and he opens the fort and
he's like how many dogs do you have
that was just really great they were
able to put humor in without taking it
away from still feeling that
violent passion that becky was feeling
because sometimes when you blend both
people over do the humor in my opinion
you don't want to also distract away
from what you're feeling emotionally
through a film and this scene too is so
important with the guy
getting killed by the ruler because
becky is
literally in this fort and i believe
truly that if she threw that key out to
him he would have left like he said
and that probably would have resolved a
lot but
that wasn't going to be the case for
becky becky thought about her mother
when he brought her up again
looks at the picture and wants justice
she also just lost her father so there
was no going back here
and that's what worked too is that you
kind of look at this film it's a perfect
villain backstory like this would be a
prequel for
any type of villain in lore and it makes
me want sequels to this because i think
they set up a really interesting
character in becky especially
now that we know how she became the way
she is
and the music was really used well here
they used a lot of tribal music with a
lot of like sound effects and heavy
breathing
and they threw heartbeats in here too
and it works because
all the music was really serving its
purpose was to
make you feel the emotion becky's
feeling in a given scene like right
after when she finds out that her dad's
getting remarried she'd just
hear this heightened tribal music and
heavy breathing and
that goes on throughout the film any
time becky has a reaction to something
extreme
and they confirm a lot how psycho a
state of mind becky is money in this
film
i mean when she gets back to the house
and she looks at amanda brugel's
character
she draws a smiley face on the window
that's very creepy and very joker like
when i was talking about just creative
violent moments i
really loved this moment when she is
literally burning
a white supremacist with his own weapon
with fire but uses a super soaker with
gas in it that was really cool to watch
but by the end of all this when we're
back at the police station she's talking
to them more this movie started
the key here is that she told them that
kevin james's crew was looking for a
canadian quarter she does not mention
this key that is on her neck
that has the white supremacist symbol on
it so i
really wonder again where are they
teasing you with becky here is she
becoming a white nationalist or she just
a crazy person or you could think so
many things here maybe she just takes it
as
a token of memory of that the time she
survived all these people
and prospered maybe that's just all teas
so
it's interesting it makes you think it's
a really fun watch
and i really love it just went balls to
the walls i thought lula wilson did
amazing
and i thought kevin james was pretty
good you know i think that
it wasn't one of those roles that it
kind of it's not that challenging it's
not showing you what he can really do
yet as a dramatic actor but i think it
has a lot of promise for him
i think he did good with what he was
given and i think there was just a lot
of good comedic writing in here it was
subtle
didn't take away from all the other
important aspects of the drama and the
motion to the film
and again great score it served its
purpose
and i think that watching it the second
time
i enjoyed it more you appreciate it more
knowing where it ends up
and seeing becky's transformation as the
film goes on and
i think that was the most effective part
how they lined it up with apex's
transformation where he was
becoming less of a killer so to me this
gets an 8.7
let me know what you thought down below
i'd love to hear your thoughts
i read every comment and try to respond
as many as i can please make sure to
check out my review of shirley that also
came out this weekend with elizabeth
moss i think you'll be interested to
hear my thoughts on that
it's not what a lot of people are
thinking about the film so i would like
to see if you agree or disagree
and please make sure to subscribe to my
channel it really helps me so much
i can't stress this enough every single
one of you i'm so grateful for so
if you could please just subscribe and
put notifications i'll be so happy
and just helps me in so many ways you
have no idea so that'd be super
appreciated
and please follow me at stevevarley1 on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time